NOT LOOK LIKE SHMOVED BY ANY OFT
THAN
PLANNED MOBILIZA O RUSSIIN
MOSCOW, ST.ER
AND .
r: REALLY THE DAY IN WHICH THE .
I SHOINT OUT FOR ORDINARY
HEARING NOW IS THE SIG THE BOMB
IN FRONT LINE
BUT PEOPLE WAKING UP IN MOSCOW
PEOPLE THEY KNOW WHO ARE NOT IN
THE AR B TO GO TO
THE FRONT LINE
SO WE ARE SEEING TICKET SALES,
MEN TRYING TT OUOFSIA.SEEING PR
NYS 1,300 PEOPLE ARRESTED
ANT NO TO THE WAR
THIS IS AFTER  OF TH
WAR AND POSSIBLY THENG
PUT THEM ON THE STREETS IS THE
FACT THAT ORDINARYS WHO
HAVEN'T BEEN IMPACTED ARE GOING
TO BE RU TO THE FRONT.
RUSSIA HASN'T OVERCOME THE HOW
WITH AN CT THAT
MEANS THESE LIVE
OR
DECISION MAKING  T
LINE.UKRAINIAPR
VOLODYR
TIME DURINA SPEE
UNITED NATIONS GENERALY
CALLING FOR RUSSIA TO BE
STRIPPED OF VETO POWERHE RUSSIA
UGGESTING IS TO SLOW D
THEIR
THE WINTER IS CERTAINLY COMING
NCLEAR A WHETHER
MOBILIZATN WILL
AFFECT ANY CHANGE ON THE TTLEFIA
OVERNIGHT.WHILE TALK WAS OL
MOBIRUSSIA, THEY
AFFECTED A PCHANGE
WHERE THE GOER TO PUTIN'S AND A
UKE POLITILLWAR, ARRESTED BY TH
SOLD WE AT THE STEEL
AN.MARKABLE PICTURES AS THEY COE
BACK TO UKRA
BRS
HEROES WHILE RUSSIA GETS BAC
L
THESE FOUR RDUMSG
THEY'RE LIKELY TO DECLARE THEY
WA TT OF RUSSIA
AND ATS PACE AS THY TION ON THEN
T'S HAPPENIN
BEFORE WINTER, BEFORE RU
HANGE ITS
BATTLEFIELD OR THENE THANK